[موسيقى]
فرقه بي تي اس من بدايه ظهورها وهي اختارت
ان هي تخطب فرقه المراهقين فئه الشباب
الصغير تتكلم بلسانهم عن هموم هم مشاكلهم
احلامهم
تعرضهم للتنمر تعرضهم لمشاكل اسريه
تفكيرهم في كل
مناح الحياه فقدره ان هي تلمس مشاعر الفئه
دي من الجمهور خصوصا مع وجود شبه كبير بين
الثقافه الكوريه والثقافه العربيه في حته
المبادئ والصداقه
والاخلاق بي تي اس بتقدم محتوى ايجابي
ومرح مليان بهجه مليان رسايل جميله عن ان
انت لازم تحب نفسك مهما كانت ان انت ما
تسمعش الرسائل السلبيه اللي بتجيلك من من
اي مكان فكل ده خلى الشباب ده يتعلق بها
حتى لو كانت اللغه بتاعتهم اللغه الكوريه
فهم بيدوروا على الترجمه بتاعه الاغاني دي
وبيسمعوها وابتدا الشباب كتير ان هو يتعلم
اللغه الكوريه اصلا من عشان يسمع الفرقه
دي بشكل احسن وبيسمع هم قصدهم قبل لغتهم
الاصليه
[موسيقى]
من اول اصلا ظهور لفرقه بي تي اس سنه 2013
وهم قدروا ان هم يخطفوا انظار الشباب
بيخطفوا
مشاعرهم
لكن اللي عمل النقله الكبيره ذكاء اعضاء
الفرقه فان هم بيقدموا رساله الحقيقيه
للمجتمع ان هم عايزين يوصلوا للناس اكتر
عملوا اغاني مش بس باللغه الكوريه لا
عملوا اغاني باللغه الانجليزيه عشان
يوصلوا لعموم عموم العالم كله اتخطوا
الحاجز اللغوي ونجحوا في ده الفرقه تطورت
من كونها فرقه كيبوب موسيقيه انها تكون
واحده من اهم مصادر السياحه لكوريا ان هم
يطلبوا حملات توعويه في اليونيسف في الامم
المتحده هم عملوا الحمله بتاعه انا احب
ذاتي اللهم يسلف فده كل ده نجاح بيميز
الفرقه في كونها مش بس فرقه موسيقيه لا ده
هي هي ثروه قوميه لكوريا
[موسيقى]
مع اول ظهور لفرقه بي تي اس تلاشى تماما
اي حد كان بيقدم محتوى الكيبوب قبلهم
الفرقه كسرت كل الارقام القياسيه في تاريخ
الموسيقى الكوريه اول فرقه كوريه تحقق
الانجاز ده في التاريخ غير عشرات الجوائز
العالميه تصدرهم لمخطط اكثر من مره كل ده
نجاحات وجوائز ما فيش فرقه كوريه قدرت
قدرت ان هي توصل لها قبل كده
[موسيقى]
واحده من اهم اسباب نجاح فرقه بي تي اس هو
علاقتهم مع الفانز بتاعهم هي علاقه خاصه
جدا علاقه حميميه جدا زي ما ذكرت اطلاقه
على نفسهم احنا جيش بي تي اس والفرقه
نفسها بتقدم لهم جلسات توقيع خاصه بيطلعوا
لايف من على حساباتهم الشخصيه على
السوشيال ميديا بيردوا على تعليقاتهم
بيتكلموا معاهم بشكل شخصي ده خلق علاقه
حميميه ونادره جدا بين الفرقه وبين
الجمهور بتاعهم فالجمهور اصبح حاسس ان في
نوع من
الانتماء للفرقه دي الفرقه دي
بتتكلم عني بتتكلم عن مشاكل بتتكلم عن
اللي بيدور في دماغي بتتكلم عن المشاعر
السلبيه اللي بفكر فيها كل ده خلق حاله
نادره جدا ده سبب من اسباب كتير لنجاح
الفرقه دي خصوصا في عالمنا العربي
[موسيقى]